la renovada ofensiva se ha desarrollado
durante el último mes los útiles
respaldados por irán en buscan
apoderarse de marín esta región rica en
petróleo es el último bastión del
gobierno en el norte de yemen la campaña
ha sido feroz han muerto cientos de
combatientes de ambos bandos perder a
mari sería un gran revés para el
gobierno y para su patrocinador la
vecina arabia saudita que ha sido blanco
de ataques transfronterizos útiles cada
vez más frecuentes en las últimas
semanas la coalición liderada por arabia
saudita ha estado luchando contra los
rebeldes durante seis años en lo que se
considera una guerra de poderes entre
riad y su archirrival irán pero el
futuro de la coalición ahora es incierto
uno de sus partidarios clave eeuu ha
puesto fin a su apoyo a las operaciones
ofensivas y detuvo la venta de armas a
arabia saudita con joe biden revirtiendo
la política de sus dos predecesores
también se ha levantado la designación
de los útiles como grupo terrorista y
nombrado a un nuevo enviado especial a
yemen
elkin en un esfuerzo por ponerle fin a
la guerra según los informes
léider quien se reunió con los útiles en
omán el mes pasado y viajó a arabia
saudita a principios de esta semana el
enviado especial en ver quién está ahora
de regreso en riad para realizar más
consultas con arabia saudita sobre cómo
resolver el conflicto y brindar alivio a
la difícil situación humanitaria del
pueblo yemení
eeuu junto con la onu busca renovar los
esfuerzos de paz múltiples esfuerzos
diplomáticos a lo largo de los años han
fracasado el conflicto se ha cobrado
decenas de miles de vidas ha desplazado
a millones y ha llevado a muchos al
borde de la hambruna en lo que la onu
califica como la peor crisis humanitaria
del mundo